tonight is the nba draft lottery
something that's been around for more
than 30 years it's believed that zion
williamson will definitely be the first
overall pick the question is who will
hold that first overall pick the knicks
are hoping that they will get a repeat
of what they got in the first draft
lottery when they secured the rights to
patrick ewing and there still continues
to be a conspiracy theory to this day
yeah that that was hashtag rigged just
like the coin toss we're about to do
for the best all-time nfl conspiracy
shoes we'll take the ideas for these
drafts wherever we can get you know it
go ahead go ahead rig coin toss you're
going to call heads today because you
think she feels sorry for me you know
what she does she feels sorry for you
for sure heads there it goes one of
these days she'll realize yeah that's
what
yes
go ahead go ahead
okay i'm going with one that i don't
even think is going to be on your list
but it hits home for me okay
i used to see this
you didn't actually have your spleen
taken out
uh no
jimmy hoffa is buried buried in the
meadowlands okay that's my favorite nfl
conspiracy theory i mean i grew up going
to the giant stadium i'm starting to you
know i'm watching games and i'm hearing
you know back in the day chris berman
talking about jim jimmy hoffa being
buried on the 20-yard line so to me uh
that is one of the best conspiracy
theories in the nfl most people think
jimmy hoffa who is you know you can help
me out with the history here that was
basically whacked white right by the
mafia yeah swac
yes because he was uh the leader of um
teamsters teamsters thank you very much
i couldn't think of that and yes that
he's somewhere buried in the meadowlands
and the rumor came about when i don't
know i'm going to say what eight late
eighties were the early nineties around
then when they started to talk about
that they think jimmy hoffa's that's
your go-to number one that's my number
wait until third round you knew i wasn't
gonna pick that one uh i didn't know for
sure i wasn't sure and why because i'm
italian well yeah i got something about
it i might have been like yeah you think
i was involved are you implicating me
you know it's great i i read the book
not that long ago wise guy we talked
about that yesterday on the podcast
goodfellas was based on the book wise
guy and actually in the book they talk
about a guy they whacked that they
buried under a bocce court and tommy joe
pesci's character was great hey how are
you doing down there ralph every time
they went by that box oh my gosh that is
that's brutal but all right
i like that i had to go with that one
it's too too fun for me all right for me
this is the no-brainer this is the
obvious one and i know that this is one
that they still talk about super bowl 47
when the lights went out in the
superdome i was there people freaked out
people didn't know what was going on and
when you're at the press box at the
superdome you are the last one out you
you ain't getting out if something's
going down in the superdome but still to
this day there are members of the
baltimore ravens from that season who
think that it was done deliberately to
give the 49ers a chance to try to come
back and win the game they ultimately
didn't but you got guys like ray lewis
who legitimize it who think that roger
goodell just kicked the
power cord out of a wall at the
superdome to deliberately cause a an
extended delay that reset the game and
and spark the 49ers i i don't think
there's anything to it but that's one of
my favorite conspiracies no i mean of
course not and didn't the city of new
orleans come out and basically say that
there was something with the transformer
i always tell the truth too in
situations like that that's what makes a
conspiracy theory good everybody lies
about it that's very true you're right
about that but i know i don't buy that
either you know again my dad was
broadcasting that football game
i mean gosh they really kept that
conspiracy very quiet for that to be
true then i mean i feel like it would
have gone out they had a lot of time to
fill they did have phil had a lot of
time a lot of time to phil i know geez
uh that was that was truly an amazing
event but yeah i'm with you there and i
don't buy that that conspiracy okay uh
i'm i'm doing ones that more are more
fun to me
this one i hear this a lot and annoys me
and people think it's a conspiracy and i
want to just go no it's just stupidity
uh that bill that bill callahan the
coach of the raiders sabotaged the super
bowl uh you know with john gruden in the
tampa bay buccaneers that was like the
biggest story right before one of the
super bowls when tim brown came out and
said that he believed that he did it
yeah no i know
it's always been out there and to help
gruden win right that's what people say
and i want to that's what people come up
to me sometimes ago i mean oh bill
callahan helped grew now and i want to
be like really come on you think bill
callahan really wanted to ruin his
legacy and not have a job as a nfl head
coach anymore just so john gruden can
win the super bowl now yeah so i'm not
of course buying into that conspiracy
now i will sit here and go that was just
absolutely completely stupid that him
and rich gannon did not change signals
and audibles i mean the guy who taught
them the offense they were running in
the super bowl was
on the other team's sideline as the head
coach did they really not think he was
gonna not tell them what black 370 smoke
was or you know uh black 358 cannon i'm
giving you some real audibles from the
john gruden office but but i got there
the next year i mean yeah they were all
over everything because john gruden
played quarterback during the week of
practice and went through all the
audibles because he knew he had wired
rich gannon to do certain things against
certain blitzes and they expose them
that way not a conspiracy just stupidity
on the raiders yeah you got to change
that stuff you can't go forward with the
stuff that you know the guy who designed
it had exactly you have to make those
changes and the sooner you make them the
better and you know that's something
like a bill belichick would never do
he'd change it all from day one yeah so
you don't have to worry about trying to
change it all two weeks before the super
bowl when it just so happens all crap
we're playing the buccaneers right all
right speaking of bill belichick yeah
this is one that that i love because
there are still members of the 2001 rams
who believe this happened they're salty
about it to this day there is no
evidence that it occurred it became a
big deal a couple of days before super
bowl 42 and i think at a certain level
the patriots would never use this as an
excuse i think it knocked them a little
wobbly going into that giants game when
they were the heavy favorite to go 19-0
right because they it all hit and they
they spent time in meetings with the
league the league swooped instead of
waiting until after the super bowl it's
like hey let's just wait until after the
super bowl with this but what became
known as spy gate 2. yes even though it
happened chronologically before the
notion that the patriots secretly
recorded the final walkthrough practice
of the la rams or the then st louis rams
and understood how big of a factor
marshall falk was going to be in the
game plan and knew exactly all of that i
don't buy it i don't believe it but
marshall falk believes it he'll talk
about it from time to time kurt warner
talks about it from time to time those
rams players believe they got cheated by
the patriots not just by the videotaping
of defensive coaching signals because
they played them twice that year but
also by this idea that their walk
through practice that super bowl 36 was
videotaped it wasn't but i love that
conspiracy theory because they are still
salty about it no i i know they are
i can always say this i never was around
a bigger rule follower in the nfl than
bill belichick i'm gonna say that i'm
gonna say it again i mean like i said
you couldn't bet five dollars on the u.s
open in the in the building in new
england so uh i have a hard time
thinking he did that you know the other
hard time the other thing uh that's
always hard to swallow is the
preparation of the new england patriots
you know again there's a reason that
this team has dominated the century to
this point we've had two decades and one
team has dominated both of them and
that's because the guy that leads that
team is on another level he is the
michael jordan of coaches or the wilt
chamberlain or whatever the hell you
want to say he is but he is so ahead of
his time for what he's doing as far as
an nfl head coach that hey i played
against bill belichick in 2005 of the
tampa bay buccaneers and damn did they
know a lot of stuff about our offense
how did they know it i don't know you
know how they knew it because bill's a
crazy dude and he studies everything in
the world and he keeps a rolling log of
oh when i played him the last time they
did this and i did this and he
accumulates all this stuff and then you
wonder how they know you know one of
your checks well because bill's crazy
enough to go back and watch tv
recordings to hear if you know the
audible's in live time or do all that
that so he does all the little things to
make you think oh gosh they must have
had us miked or do all that but no what
he really did was outwork everybody and
out detail everybody and it just seems
like he knows what you're doing better
than what you know and he's been doing
it for 19 years exactly
and they got six super bowls because of
it all right what's your next one okay i
mean
i'm stuck here between the immaculate
reception
and i i don't know why i kind of i don't
really look at that as a conspiracy so
the one i want to i'm going to do this
one i want to do the russell wilson pass
at the end of the football game
to me not only because
conspiracy theory is actually one i
think i believe in i guess that's why i
want to pick it and and marshawn lynch
went on tv in turkey to articulate his
conspiracy theory about why they passed
instead of running i i mean my theory
and i know uh and if you talk to some of
the people i was watching the game at
the time i was saying this you know
daryl bevel was the offensive
coordinator of the seattle seahawks i
truly believe that it wasn't against
marshawn lynch i think more or not
though he said man if i get a touchdown
pass and russell wilson's the mvp of the
super bowl that's going to get me a head
coaching job as a and get me bumped up
from offensive coordinator to head coach
i really believe that was the reason
they called that play there i mean i i
mean again i don't know why you wouldn't
give the ball how about just win the
super exactly right why wouldn't you
give the ball the most powerful running
back in the sport behind one of the more
powerful lines in the sport at the time
so to me yeah that's a conspiracy theory
that i you know there there's some truth
to it for me all right i'm going to have
some fun with this one because i i've
i've already won i don't even have to
pick in round three jimmy you can't be
jimmy hoffman stupid i win it's not a
conspiracy why it's a definition of it
legend well okay
so is so is the blackout i mean so it's
a conspiracy thing oh why because
there's people who actually involved who
believe who talk about it when you've
got players like ray lewis talking about
it that gives life to it
this is just it just happened to be the
location that's jimmy hoffa had nothing
to do with the nfl you just found it on
google during the commercial and you
decided it reminded me yeah it reminded
me of it i won't deny that this happened
at giant stadium as well yeah the old
giant stadium yeah when the vikings and
the giants played in the 2000 nfc
championship i was there yeah okay and
when there was some sort of
surreptitious interception of the viking
signals uh from that that bubbled up
right after the game and it went away
really quickly but there was something
going on there where the giants did
something there's a conspiracy theory
i'm not saying it happened i've never
even heard of this theory okay
i'm telling you 41 to nothing the
vikings were a great team that year the
giants were average at best as the super
bowl showed right there was something
about signals being intercepted
communications being intercepted and the
vikings just falling apart yeah okay hey
i i don't know i don't think to excuse
41 donuts apparently yeah that was a
butt whooping that game was over before
it started you know when when i hear
about like signals being stolen and
things like that too at times and i know
we just talked about this a little
i want to go
okay first of all did you expect that a
multi-million dollar business that's you
know standing 50 yards away from you not
gonna have somebody looking across
trying to steal signals now i understand
we don't want cameras filming things and
all that but i look at it more times
than not if your signal signals are
being stolen that is on you that you're
not changing your signals more you know
like you talked about new england would
never be caught doing that uh peyton
manning in his prime no great team would
be because every week every few weeks
the coach the quarterback they go hey we
gotta change that up we've we've used
that like 12 times the last month so we
got to give a new one or you start to
give dummy signals to go you know hey
i'm going to give a signal that we
always give but it's not real and you
have a code word for it so now the team
they might be onto our signals but now
they have no idea what's going on
because some of them are fake those are
the things you have to do uh when it
comes to that type of stuff all right
quick recap before we take our break
sims has jimmy hoffa being buried at
giant stadium as his favorite nfl
conspiracy theory followed by bill
gallahan does it sabotaging super bowl
37 the decision to pass not run at the
end of super bowl 49 i've got the super
bowl 47 blackout spy gate 2 prior to
super bowl 36 and the 2000 nfc
championship game where there's a belief
that the giant jimmy hoffa was there and
he helped the signals for the giants to
win
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports